Kevin McCarthy booting controversial
Democrats from key house committees the
new speaker making good on his promise
to remove Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell
from house Intel Republicans say
swalwell can't be trusted after his
relationship with suspected Chinese spy
Fang Fang and Schiff being shown the
door for saying things like this
I've been very clear over the last year
a year and a half that there is ample
evidence of collusion in plain sight in
fact Every Act that I pointed to as
evidence of collusion has now been borne
out by the report the obstruction of
justice in particular in this case is
far worse than anything that Richard
Nixon did I would say in every way this
is more significant than Watergate
ilhan Omar also being removed from the
Foreign Affairs committee over
anti-semitic comments GOP rep Byron
Donald shutting down msnbc's Joy Reid
while pointing out Democrats set the
precedent of kicking members off the
Committees
what we told Democrat leadership when
they went down this this pathway of
removing members from committee is
basically saying you should not do that
because if it's good for the goose it's
good for the gander let's be very clear
Elon Omar has said things that are
reprehensible sounds like using
committee leadership
you want to change the rules and we'll
live by your rules yes it is true like
it's it's as if judged that the
Democrats don't see past one news cycle
to see what could happen for example
when McConnell said if you lower the
threshold to confirming judges that is
going to come back to hurt you they did
it and now who the majority on the
Supreme Court are the conservatives
conservatives exactly and you know what
the the truth is that the decision to
make these uh these are momentous
momentous things that they're doing I
mean to have one party the majority be
able to take someone off a committee
because they're not a member of the
party but you know what if McCarthy
didn't do that a lot of people would be
very upset with him because they did it
to our party and you know the there's
good reason I have to tell you I mean
when you've got small well with this
relationship with Fang thing or thing is
a Fang bang or Fong Fong all right she
worked in the in his campaign and she
also was personally involved with him
and and you know Adam Schiff the guy is
lying through his teeth this guy is
literally perjuring himself in front of
the American people he doesn't belong on
a committee and ilhan Omar has shown how
her anti-Semitism is literally a bar to
her being on the Foreign Affairs
committee but I also want to
congratulate uh McCarthy on the fact
that there is right now a resolution
house resolution 8 for the impeachment
of mayorkas I mean they're going to town
the Republicans just the way they said
they would
shift guaranteed that President Trump
would basically be in jail and he was on
the Intel committee going on TV saying I
know that this is happening yes and he
never offered any evidence because as
the judge says he's a liar if it you
know if it weren't for these Republicans
right now
these clowns would basically have tenure
despite lacking any credibility
whatsoever Schiff created complete
hoaxes uh um swalwell is a security
sieve and an embarrassment even without
the flatulence and all I can say about
Omar is oh brother
but it does show you another contrast
between Democrats and Republicans that
do to Media scrutiny Republicans can't
afford to have nuts for very long though
you're like right-wing noise makers who
are let's say one quarter the absurdity
in idiocy of Adam Schiff come and go
like that they're out like look at look
what's happening to Santos and compared
to Schiff he's harmless but you know if
he survives I'd be surprised but you
know but the insaniacs on the Democrat
side they can stick around forever
whether it's Maxine Waters or Adam
Schiff they're like swalwell's lingering
flatulence
is what is good for the goose good for
the game ah I've never heard that before
it started as what's good for the goose
there's been new developers from Top Gun
yes ah I like this story better if we
could see them get the boot I want to
see the sergeant of arms come into the
Committee hearing grab them by the elbow
and then escort them out like a bouncer
because it's hard for me to imagine them
being booted I like the idea that
Republicans want on the numbers because
if they kicked out Paul golzer all due
respect to Paul I don't think anybody
knows who he is and Marjorie Taylor
green Republicans kicked out Schiff Omar
and swallow those are big name IDs and
that's three to two so that's very good
and I'm glad he's off the committee too
Schiff because what does he judge he's a
liar and a sack of shift I was gonna go
with leaker but that's good yeah I was
too permission to make an analogy all
right
uh this would be like oh boy just
kidding this would be like me saying
I'm only allowed to interrupt Jessica
if Jessica interrupts me that's not
allowed
it's actually kind of like that role
pretty sure that's the Credo you live by
anyway and a few days ago you got
jealous that other people were
interrupting me and you couldn't because
you were leaving okay
um so a couple things that I think are
relevant Marjorie Taylor green who is a
big name in the Republican party I would
say and now she I mean she's made
herself a top McCarthy age she even had
well the video is down because Dr Dre
was mad that she used his music but she
has made herself her his right hand she
was kicked off of committees for social
media post advocating for violence
against Democrats that's very different
from making comments for being wrong
about an Intel issue and everything
that's going on because we have a
democratic controlled Senate and a
Democratic president in the house it's
mostly symbolic and swallow was due to
be a rotated office committee Omar's
assignment relied on a vote obviously
the GOP was not going to vote to put her
back on the Foreign Affairs committee
but on the shift point
a lot of what he said obviously turned
out to be wrong but I would be
interested to see a montage let's say of
Republicans hyping the Durham report
how that was going to expose the Deep
State and ways we could never understand
and what did John Durham end up with a
big obvious there's a difference he's a
lawyer who said he saw the I just want
the Montage someone can make someone at
home maybe you can make it for me
I want to see people like Jim Jordan
prominent Republicans a lot in the
Senate as well saying just you wait and
see till we get what John Durham but
they say and he couldn't get one
conviction that judge laughed at him
that would work if any of those people
I'm not saying that if any of them had
said I know because I've seen and I
guarantee that that is what ship said
and that's that's obviously totally
different
and that's the end of it
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now